- I think when we were
putting together the writers
it was just the funniest
people we could find.
- Everybody was my first choice.
They're the funniest
people I know,
and also the worst
people I know.
(upbeat rock music)
- From the very beginning,
it was like Jessi.
- I first met Jessi
just through stand-up
and she had this
amazing joke I loved
about how Cosmo writes articles
like "How to Give a Blow
Job while You're Crying".
- 2000 men are suing Cosmo
magazine for emotional damages.
- I bet you guys didn't know
you could fit a Hanukkah
candle in your pee hole.
Well guess what Cosmo?
You can't and now I have
to pee in a series of bags.
- [Amy] Gabe Liedman,
I know from stand-up.
I would do some shows
together at like aidsy places.
- You look ferocious, Amy.
- The gayest, bestest friend
a girl could ever have.
I think he would be
totally fine with me
describing him that way.
- I'm like a real man, Ame.
- [Amy] Damn.
- I fucked you
right in your pussy.
- Tig, I was like,
please write for my show.
- Tada.
- Dry wit.
- Tig makes me laugh
because she's got,
I don't know, you just
interviewed her now, right?
Did she do that cold
dead lesbian stand to
the camera she does?
My God, she made me stare
into her eyes the other day.
- Will you stare at
me for a little while?
I just sometimes stare
at him when we're
in the writers' room.
He's just like this huge man.
- He definitely knows
how to push buttons
and for that he gets fired
several times a week.
- Oh my God, Kurt I totally
forgot to tell you this.
- What?
- You're fired.
- Amy runs the show much
like a Jim Jones style
Guyanese cult and that's
one of the many games
to break you down.
- I started stand-up with him.
He decided that he had
like this huge crush on me.
- We actually went
on like two dates.
- And then one night
I realized like,
why I wasn't interested.
- [Kurt] I look
exactly like her dad.
(dramatic music)
- She's gross for even having
gone on those two dates with
me as far as I'm concerned.
- I think Kurt is hilarious
and just a total degenerate.
- The man's orgasm
is loud and awful.
- Whoa! Whoa!
- Kurt, don't go subtle.
- Kyle is very like sweet
and lovely and then ...
- Nuts! Nuts!
- [Kurt] My favorite
sketch is Nutters.
- It's something I
thought of a while ago.
It's like Hooters,
but it's for women.
- [Kurt] So they showcase
their nuts, their like,
nut cleavage.
- It's Nutters.
I mean it's a simple premise.
- I think it should
be two sacks.
- [Jessi] Two sacks!
Give me two sacks.
- Come on give me
a couple sacks.
- Come on Jim, touch 'em.
- I'm excited it's
gonna come to fruition.
- Ouch! Easy Jim.
- I live with Kyle and Tig.
They have bunk beds.
I'm sure they told you
that they have bunk beds.
- There they are.
I probably should have
cleaned it up first.
- It's pretty ...
- [Kyle] What?
(screams happily)
- Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, Amy.
- We do a lot of bits.
- [Kyle] ♪ Here a lay,
by myself, in my poop.
- Some of the things
that have happened
at the apartment have
popped up in the sketches.
- "♪ And livin' like a swamp"
- "♪ There's a
possum in your heart"
- [Kyle] Where did we go?
- Possum in your heart.
- "♪ Possum, possum"
- "♪ Possum's bleeding
on your torso"
- "♪ Livin' in your heart"
- [Amy] Working with them and
then also living with them
has been so fun.
I'm just weirdly living
with these two people
in their forties,
that have bunk beds.
(upbeat rock music)
- Vegas.
I've just been
going on the road,
getting ready for the stand-up
that's gonna be on the show.
Nothing makes you as strong
as going on the road.
My sister has never
been to Vegas.
I feel like she's gonna love it.
Two of you, two of us.
I'll do the math.
Oh shit!
Vegas!
Vegas knows how to
fuck you in the ass.
What?
(upbeat rock music)
(squeak)